head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
timcast.com
Biden's speech won final warning
according to white house chief of staff
in some cases we won't know the winner
of the election for a few days after the
election said Biden of midterm results
one final warning that's what he says
the president decided a few days ago
that it was important to issue one final
warning on this issue to make very clear
to leave no doubt that we have people
out there still peddling the big lie
people uh now raising the issue of
election Denial in this election one
final warning oh yeah old mean Joe's
coming for you if you say naughty words
about him
what's the one final warning a warning
to Democrats that there's going to be
people who reject the results or
whatever
I don't understand how that makes sense
because Democrats rejected the elections
in 2016. outright rejected it and Stacy
Abrams still does
so what what's the warning what's what's
the pitch in this speech by uh Biden was
basically saying the only way democracy
survives is if Democrats retain power
pretty much I mean that's essentially
what he's saying here if we lose there's
going to be something fishy going on but
but if we win you better not say
something especially going on and again
this is just power trying to hold on to
power and they're losing it they're
losing it's it's just getting gripped
out of their hands right now and one
final warning I mean that sounds like a
threat that's like what parents say to
their children like one last warning and
then I'm gonna spank you it's like okay
like basically you're saying if we don't
vote for you we don't vote for your
candidates we're going to be punished is
kind of how it reads because it's like
well why can't we evaluate the
candidates in front of us and decide
this is an election but he's basically
saying before the election even starts
we're already in a place where you know
they're going to bring the hammer on us
well let's be fair we are being punished
because people voted for them so in 2020
they decided Biden was the guy and now
we all suffer because of it so hopefully
we're in the midterms you know we're not
going to change the executive branch
unless the they impeach him and then
Kamala
and then I guess you have to appoint a
republican speaker of the house could
you imagine a president McCarthy I would
not be happy but it's better than a
president Kamala like if he had to
choose I think the reason uh Biden put
in Kamala is because so many other
people would rather have him than Kamala
I mean if you're asking me right now who
do you want at the position of power
right now Kamala a sociopathic crazy
prosecutor from California or just the
old man who doesn't know where he is I
prefer the old man to be honest with you
what about you guys or the woman the the
one that has cognitive cognizance I
can't stand vacant leadership but Biden
is surrendering why would you want a
competent working government
negotiate certain things with bad people
but not crazy people if look if Joe
Biden or or you know let's we won't use
Joe Biden if an 80 year old unhinged
demented man broke into your house on
accident and he was armed and he's in
your house and he's got he's he's got a
powerful weapon
what are you gonna say to him you're
gonna be like hey there calm down buddy
what's going on he's gonna be like hey
you better care bang bang you're like oh
he's he's going nuts a crazy person
breaks in intending to do you harm now
that's bad but still equally as
dangerous however you can still talk
your way out if the person is sane you
see what I'm saying so my point is I
don't think Kamala Harris is going to
blow the world up but Joe Biden's old
and demented and may give or give orders
pertaining to the wrong country because
he's misspoken how many times he thinks
his son died in Iraq it's like it's
something he made up that's scary yeah
but still Kamala has lower approval
ratings than Biden right now oh great so
then she'll get impeached too yeah I
also feel like it's just bigger than
Biden and Kamala Harris I think we need
to like bring pain to the Democrats you
know it's like they kept impeaching
Trump they'd say oh you know this many
times impeached he's disgraced Trump
blah blah blah it's like I'm sorry but
Trump was way more popular than you guys
so we should absolutely impeach them it
doesn't even matter if you know it's
it's Biden and terrorists it's like
they're they're they're horrible but
they should have to live with that stain
because that's what they brought on us
and they always think oh we can do
whatever we want to you guys and you'll
never do it to us it's like wait a
minute if we take back the house the Sun
and we can we we can do it to you guys
maybe then they won't act like this
anymore
I don't know impeach them for what
exactly
Biden yeah impeach Biden over the
southern border I could name a whole
bunch of stuff yeah like but I can't say
some of it
uh the two things I can't say on this
channel one relates to a product one
relates to the treatment two relates
three uh International Chinese business
dealing it's Hunter it's Hunter business
dealings Afghanistan uh strategic
petroleum Reserve that's the big one
right there gutting our strategic
petroleum Reserve to try and win an
election while destroying domestic
energy production and exploration
sending money to Ukraine I just just
just just sorry go he's Gotta Go I mean
what he did in Afghanistan that's just
criminality right there that's that's
that's beyond words of it's not a
competence it wasn't a mistake it's it's
top level criminality you're talking
about the surrender yeah yeah the
business dealings with China the
business dealings with Ukraine there's
so much to look into but also let's 25th
amendment him
okay we're not going to say he did
anything wrong we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna go out with some Grace and
just say his brain don't work gotta go
on if it's a rule right gotta go yeah
unfit I haven't thought much about I
thought impeachment is just kind of like
political football like now now it's
your turn next time it'll be my turn
then your turn but at some point doing
nothing is probably the wrong move like
just waiting for incompetence to leave
it doesn't want to leave they'll stick
around until you make him get out so
maybe maybe an impeachment is on the
table
I certainly think so I I think the best
government is the government that
doesn't do anything so the more
incompetent they are the more that
they're stalled the more that they don't
do anything the more happy you are I am
because that means the government's
going to be interfering with my life a
lot less so I'm happy that there's going
to be I I think all governments should
always have a big checks of balance on
it I think if a president is Democrat
there should be a republican uh Senate
and House to challenge him on everything
I think there should always be huge
arguments and debates I think they have
to be there for every single vote I
think they need to work at a snail's
pace and if they do that I'll be very
happy I think it would have been great
if Trump appointed Tulsi gabbard as like
National Security advisor and um
I mean yeah just right just just right
there then you're bringing in someone
who's more moderate more left lane this
is especially this was back a few years
ago when she was absolutely a Democrat I
think that would have built up a massive
Coalition and probably would have Tulsi
voters would be like we'll take it
National Security adviser to the
president Tulsi anti-intervention way
better than John Bolton I think we'll
start getting kind of stuff like that if
we have chank yuger on the show once we
start doing it personally when we can
work with the people the most extremely
different invited him on the show
politely never stop keep going because
he's on his way but once we start I
think as citizenry Reaching Across the
aisle interacting with people that we
might have thought our enemies
psychologically and we really can show
in good faith that we can work together
and though we disagree you'll start to
see it in politics you know the issue I
take that with that Ian is I think
you're saying that out of ignorance and
naivety no I mean I just think you'd be
the change don't expect someone else to
do it well I heard that somewhere I've
been on the ground for uh I I was
reporting on the ground for like
10 years
and I've been all over these protests
Luke and I were in occupy
having experienced this and knowing
firsthand exactly what happens when you
try and say words to these people I can
only just say to you Ian you are 100
incorrect what you are proposing is like
asking someone to flap their arms until
they fly it won't happen when when I saw
Jen Huger at Politico I said hey man
how's it going because I know him and
I've known him for a long time
he fans me off and I was like hey look
guys you guys made a video about Dave
Rubin I don't know what your beef I have
nothing to do with it but you put my
name like front center in your video so
I was just wondering if you could they
just start screaming at me top of his
lungs in front of everybody at politicon
and I'm just like why are you yelling at
me like what's happening we've invited
him on the show numerous times all they
do is they make rage bait videos about
us taking us out of context when I
invited some of these these high profile
leftists come on the show what do they
do they lied and claimed that we were
tricking them for for to grift or
whatever and then went around hooting
and hollering that I was afraid to
debate or something it was totally fake
so at a certain point yes I get it we'll
keep trying we'll keep saying things
like we'd love to have you on the show
but bro at a certain point you have to
understand that it's just not going to
happen well there are things we have in
common with pretty much every American
well maybe not every American but you
look corporate corporations Mega
corporations the amount of power mega
Corporation has over the everyday
Americans life is completely unethical I
think that [ __ ] I know Cheng euger
believes that I believe that I know that
I believe you believe that as well
you've talked we talked extensively
about BlackRock and the power that
Microsoft has and these crazy
corporations
and it's as long as we focus on our
common beliefs the little stuff like who
said what what color shirt you know who
and who you voted for that stuff doesn't
work AOC she's hardcore Progressive she
has now allied with like big military
she's allying with all of these things
she's supposed to be against it's like I
would love to think people stick to
their principles but for the left it's
like for them it's die hard it's like we
will stick as a team even if it means
going against everything we believe in
like I I know that that's probably not
something she believes in but she's
gonna do it because like she's a team
player but our side's always like we
have to be you know upright on every
single thing so then we get kind of
divided we have like Libertarians like
social conservatives like these all
these different groups and then we all
discuss things like normal people but
they just like think that we shouldn't
exist they think Tucker Carlson
shouldn't exist they hate us remember
when I explained bugs bunnying someone
do you remember this oh vaguely tell me
again so uh in Looney Tunes there's Bugs
Bunny and there's uh was it was it Daffy
Daffy Duck and then Elmer Fudd has his
double barrel and he wants to figure out
which of these small Woodland creatures
he will kill
and so there's a poster on a tree and it
says rabbit season
so then Bugs Bunny tears the flyer off
and it says duck season and then Elmer
turns the gun to Daffy and then Daffy
goes no it's rabbit season then he tears
it down it says rabbit and then Elmer
Fudd turns into bugs they go back and
forth arguing that it's actually the
other person's season then finally Bugs
Bunny reverses his position and says
it's rabbit season and then Daffy goes
oh no you don't it's duck season and
then bugs goes okay Daffy it's duck
season and then armor fight shoots Daffy
instead and then he goes you uh bugs
bunnying is a term that I I I I I use to
describe when you go on Facebook and you
will see a leftist arguing about why
they hate this that or otherwise and
then what you do is you engage them
arguing their point and slowly evolve
your position to be their original
position and they will argue against
their actual post dude this happens all
the time and I do it to make a point and
then I'll say wait a minute you're now
against social health care this is so
weird and they'll be like well well what
I'm saying is and I'm just like that's
the point the point is they hate you
they hate you so much they will vote for
Joe Biden they hate you so much they can
hear John fetterman go and they're gonna
bet I'd rather have that I mean I don't
think it's no one hates people don't
hate me you could say they hate you it's
just such a generic vague term it
doesn't dude
on his show and said we looked this up
the story never happened and if you
Google it you find the videos are viral
this guy from Dearborn said I used to be
a Democrat I'm voting Republican and
Colbert goes on his show and said we
looked up never happened
and he goes that happened everyone's
laughing and he's mocking this family
who's begging for help this guy says I
went to the Democrats and said why are
you showing sexual images to my children
and they dismissed me and when he went
to tutor Dixon and said no more will I
vote for them Colbert went on a show
lied to the entire country because they
are evil people
he could have said this guy fund he
could have said you know that story did
happen but what was this guy really
complaining about books that were
educating kids he could have made an
argument instead he just calls the guy a
liar and then claims I looked it up it
didn't happen see this is why you have
so many people who hate and will vote
for John fetterman or Joe Biden because
they March in lockstep Behind These evil
individuals and that's the banality of
evil but then for you to be alike we
should invite them on the show we do we
do but come on dude we know for a fact
they're not coming on they go on Twitter
every single day and lie about
everything
have made video after video where you
know we did not say the things they
claim we said I really don't care I made
it and take me out of context if you
want to it's not going to stop me from
trying to work the point is what makes
you think they will sit down and have a
real conversation with you when they are
lying about you to everyone else what I
believe is there is no other that maybe
there are other ways of peacefully
figuring this out but that it's like I
don't see theological right peace
I'm not trying to stop chant euger from
invading Poland right now
um no it's not about Neville
Chamberlain's weakness I'm talking about
diplomacy and communication amongst
civilians in the United States he wasn't
talking he was talking to German Nazi
Hitler dude uh
this is that's the goal I see the goal
is us hanging out talking about stuff
and showing the world that we can
overcome our grievances I don't know
exactly how to get there but I know that
that's a goal I think they silence us
what if they're like oh we want to say
our view they want to say their view
then they censor you like on on social
media like for the average person right
it's like they can't actually get their
views across and then not to mention
what about during like the BLM riots all
of that what if you're a store owner
you're like please don't hurt me I'm
liberal I support BLM please don't hurt
me and then they're like boom I'm gonna
ruin your store right so it's like okay
how is that going to work when people
have this complete hatred of you how
about that I think what Ian is trying to
say is be careful of mass
generalizations because there are Bad
actors that do hate you it's not always
everyone I think that's what you're
trying for sure but also I just wanted
to make another argument just to counter
your point a little bit here because
when you say you know they're all in
line here we should do the same I I
don't think we should because I think
not being a line I think questioning and
arguing is a strength and I think their
cultist beliefs and ideas staying in
line is a weakness and overall a bad
thing let me pull up this I think we
should be like AOC I don't think we
should give up like our principles in
order to sell out to some you know
company I'm not
saying that I do think the left goes to
the extreme to do that and our side
generally doesn't do that thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time